- Former President Trump, leaves office
with one last parting shot of corruption
because of course he would.
His last acts in office
included a raft of pardons
that are bad.
They are historically bad,
even without the prior pardons
and grants of clemency that
involve pardoning Paul Manafort
and a bunch of his cronies,
this would have been
amongst the most corrupt
and despicable group
of pardons in history.
But even as bad as they are,
it's hard not to take a step back
and recognize that it could
have been so, so much worse.
But finally, it seems
that there might actually
be a silver lining here,
because the bar was so
low with this presidency
that we can finally step over it for once.
So, let's take stock and let's see
the good and the bad here.
Let's start with the bad news first.
Because these pardons are bad.
They are historically bad.
We start with a pardon for friend
of the president, Steve Bannon.
Bannon was facing a trial
for fraud in connection
to the "Build the Wall" campaign,
and all signs point to Bannon
stealing millions of dollars
from actual Trump supporters.
And it's also notable that other
"Build The Wall" defendants
who have also been accused
and indicted of fraud
were not pardoned.
It was just the president's friend.
As former representative.
Justin Amash said,
"It went from Mexico will pay for it,
to you will pay for it to,
you will pay Steve Bannon,
and I will pardon him for defrauding you."
There's no good reason for this pardon.
There's no reason at all for this pardon
except that it's good to be a friend
of Donald Trump and swear omerta to him.
And that of course takes
us to another good friend
of Donald Trump, Elliot Broidy,
who pleaded guilty last year to conspiring
to violate foreign lobbying laws,
to influence the Trump administration
on behalf of Chinese
and Malaysian interests.
And he of course was implicated
in what is now known as
a pay for pardon scheme.
Is there anything corrupt
with this particular pardon
for a Republican fundraiser
who happens to be friend
with the former president?
All signs point to yes on that one.
And then there were more
pardons for corrupt Republicans,
like Rick Renzi and Duke Cunningham.
Renzi is a Republican and former member
of the house who was sentenced
to three years in prison
in connection with a bribery scheme
related to real estate.
Cunningham also pleaded
guilty to taking $2.4 million
in bribes from military contractors.
These are not good people.
And there's just this pattern
of pardoning outright criminal corruption.
We'd never seen anything like it
with presidential pardons before.
Yes, a lot of former
presidents seem to have a habit
of pardoning light corruption
for those who happen to be well connected,
but here, the worse the corruption,
the more likely to get a pardon.
And the corrupt are a
preponderance of the pardons.
It exists on both sides of the aisle.
While there's certainly a preponderance
of corrupt Republicans
who have received pardons,
that pattern continued with
pardoning former Detroit mayor,
Kwame Kilpatrick, who
was convicted in 2013
for using his office to enrich himself
through kickbacks, shakedowns
and bid rigging schemes.
President Trump was clearly
favoring his friends
and business partners,
but at the same time,
he was just setting a precedent
for absolving pure corruption.
Pure political and business
related corruption.
As political commentator,
Josh Barro put it,
"They only make sense
as a general statement
that corruption is good."
And that pattern of pardoning
just outright corruption,
specifically with an emphasis
on real estate corruption,
continues with the list of
people who received pardons.
For example, Sholam
Weiss, who was sentenced
to more than 800 years in
prison for racketeering,
fraud and money laundering
related to insurance fraud.
And then Eliyahu Weinstein,
who was sentenced
to more than 20 years in prison
for a real estate Ponzi scheme
that cost $200 million in damages.
And then oddly, Anthony Levandowski,
who pleaded guilty to stealing IP related
to driverless cars when he
left Google to go to Uber.
And the list of overtly
corrupt individuals
who received a pardon is extremely long.
But lest you think that Trump
was only pardoning corruption,
he also engaged in pure cronyism.
Like pardoning New York
observer's Ken Kurson,
who was charged with
cyber-stalking last fall,
and who happens to be a very, very
good friend of Jared Kushner.
And then as potentially the
very last act in office,
president Trump had one
last pardon to dish out
after the raft that he released
at 1:30 in the morning.
He also pardoned Albert Pirro,
who was a real estate
developer and notably
was the ex-husband of judge
Jeanine Pirro from Fox news.
Pirro had been convicted of conspiracy
and tax evasion in 2000.
And they had actually
represented Trump himself
in some real estate deals.
To say that these people
are undeserving of pardons
is a vast, vast understatement.
And of course, potentially
as a cherry on top,
at one o'clock in the morning,
president Trump revoked his
2017 "Drain the Swamp" memo,
which prevented members of the White House
from lobbying the
government for five years
so that the members of his administration
can now lobby the government.
- It is time to drain the
swamp in Washington, DC.
- In retrospect, looking
at all of these actions
which were entirely foreseeable,
it's not hard to see
why people who thought
that president Trump was the
anti-corruption president
and would actually drain the swamp,
also happened to believe in
stupid conspiracy theories
and absurd prognostications
that never came true.
But, if you did believe any of
those preposterously dumb
things, please contact me.
I have some really interesting
investment opportunities.
You might even call them unbelievable.
But let's also take
stock that this actually
could have been much, much worse.
President Trump could
have pardoned himself
and caused an actual
constitutional crisis.
Now, of course, the masochistic sportsman
in me kind of wanted to see it,
just so that that theory
that the president
could pardon himself would be smacked down
in front of the Supreme court
as part of a Trump corruption
and criminal investigation.
It's also entirely possible that Trump
could have pardoned members of
his family, including Ivanka,
Jared Kushner, Don Jr.
Eric, Kimberly Guilfoyle.
And it appears that he really
really wanted to do that,
but then White House
counsel, Pat Cipollone,
said it would open Trump himself
up to personal liability
or criminal liability.
And so the reason for him
not undertaking these actions
which he apparently wanted to do,
is that Donald Trump
is selfish to the core
and is willing to throw his
own children under the bus.
It's possible that he could have pardoned
his own personal attorney, Rudy Giuliani,
who's under investigation for
many fraud related things.
It's also entirely possible
that president Trump
could have pardoned his own
personal business associates.
Like, Trump Organization
CFO, Allen Weisselberg,
who also has been implicated
in all kinds of Trump related fraud.
He could have pardoned
the Capitol rioters.
some of the Congress people
who helped to foment some
of the Capitol riots,
including Congressmen Biggs and Gosar,
who apparently sought
pardons for their role
in creating the Capitol riots.
And one has to ask, if you're looking
for a preemptive pardon,
are you worried about criminal
liability related there too?
I'm going to cover this
in a video shortly.
We're lucky that there were only a handful
of celebrity pardons for some reason.
Including Lil Wayne, Kodak Black
and Harry-O of Death Row Records.
And Joe Exotic of Tiger King fame
is not amongst the pardonees.
And the ultimate good news
is that none of these pardons
affect the impeachment trial in the Senate
that remains in the short term horizon.
And of course, a new department of justice
can create new criminal investigations
and unearth all of the untoward doings
of the late Trump presidency.
Of course, it's going to
take a long, long time
to undo the damage of
the Trump presidency.
But, like allowed orange fart,
the noxious Trump presidency
is already departing the room.
And of course it's important to recognize
that none of this was normal.
The Trump presidency ended like it began
as former president George Bush said,
with some weird (beep).
And I look forward to covering
the Biden administration.
I will cover any dubious legal strategies
that they undertake.
My lawsuit against the
White House will continue
because it's about transparency
not about partisanship.
But make no mistake, the last
four years were not normal.
And as a reminder, Donald
Trump is now a private citizen,
to the extent that he ever
had immunity as president,
he no longer has immunity for anything.
These pardons are largely unjust,
but they likely won't have
systemic reverberations.
Or at least those reverberations
should be dampened.
Many who received these
pardons might even face civil
and state-based criminality down the line.
These pardons are bad,
but they're likely not earth shattering.
By all appearances, the damage of
the Trump administration was
extensive but it's contained.
And now it's time to clean up the mess.